das ist einer der erdähnlichen planeten
die bisher vom planeten sucher kepler
entdeckt wurden 77 11 werden ja schon
über die neue version der exoplaneten
liste berichtet aber noch nicht über
diesen spektakulären fund laut der
wissenschaftlerin natalie batalha ist es
der erdähnliche planet den kepler
bisher entdeckt hat mehr über einen
fund der durchaus umstrittene sekte
krieg zum seitenwechsel
kettler ist ein besonderer satellit der
kreis nämlich nicht um die erde sondern
um die sonne genau wie die erde zieht er
seine bahnen um unser zentralgestirn um
nicht bei der erdumkreisung ständig
durch den erdschatten gestört zu werden
so hat kepler freie bahnen kann
ungestört nach exoplaneten suchen
dafür wurde das weltraumteleskop
nämlich 2009 in den weltraum geschickt
eben um exoplaneten und vor allem
erdähnliche zu finden
inzwischen ist die liste der kandidaten
für exoplaneten ziemlich lang geworden
bei der beobachtung von 190.000 sterns
kepler immerhin auf rund 4.000 mögliche
exoplaneten westhofen und rund 50 von
ihnen sind er endlich darüber hat mir
ja berechtigt allerdings ist ein
kandidat vor 7711 etwas besonders steht
dabei für keppler objekt oft
interessante keppler objekt von
interesse
neben siem 11 befindet sich nämlich in
der umlaufbahn um einen stern der
unserer sonne ziemlich ähnliche film
zudem in der habitablen also
lebensfreundlichen zone um liegt die
höchsten also nicht zu weit weg dann
würde es zu kalt und nicht zu nah
dann wäre es zu heiß zudem ist bei 77
11 nur wenig größer als die erde und
hat mit 302 tagen auch eine ähnliche
umlaufzeit um den stern mittlerin nach
dem massaker vom kepler projekt sagt das
was mit g 77 11 zum ersten mal ein
planet dabei ist er mit einem rund 30
prozent größerem umfang und einer
umlaufzeit um den stern von etwa einem
jahr der erde sehr ähnlich sei bei
seiner position in der habitablen zone
zudem die existenz von wasser und damit
leben wer was schreiben ich konnte 77 1
1 wäre damit tatsächlich einer der
top-kandidaten für außerirdisches
leben doch es gibt letztlich zu viele
fragezeichen gibt es wirklich wasser hat
der planet ein magnetfeld bleibt eine
atmosphäre schützen würde eine eigene
rotation und so weiter er müsste halt
noch zahlreiche bedingungen erfüllen um
wirklich ein kandidat für leben auf
einem exoplaneten zu werden trotzdem
zeigt die entdeckung von käufen wie man
sein
da wird mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
ersten zahlreiche planeten die idealen
bedingungen für leben geben könnte und
das war mit weitem die
wahrscheinlichkeit steigt erdähnliche
planeten zu finden und auch solche auf
denen leben dann kaffee
nicht möglich ist und tritt könnten
wir dann auch wirklich leben finden noch
irgend wer wirklich halb blind ins
weltall auch bei kettler nicht mehr voll
funktionsfähig ist und weil die
auflösung der aktuellen telescope in
den neuen weltraumteleskopen deutlich
hinterher hin wenn nächstes jahr das
james webb weltraumteleskop ins all
startet und 2009/10 seine arbeit
aufnimmt dann werden wir eine neue stufe
der forschung erreichen können dafür
diesen weltraumteleskop hat eine achtung
hundertfach bessere auflösung als wir
werden so viel mehr über das weltall
erfahren auch wird damit eine neue stufe
erreichen es wird hier nur so
sensationellen news treffen aber auch
jetzt schon gibt es hier täglich neue
videos mit teilweise wirklich
unglaublichen wissenschafts news denn
schon jetzt gibt es immer öfter fahren
brechen wir erkenntnisse zu berichten
wenn ihr kein video davon verpassen
wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergessen steht auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit außerirdisches
leben auf proxima centauri b ein
weiterer kandidat für außerirdisches
leben und ansonsten braucht wenn es euch
interessiert also anfangs dann bleibt
dran